Disney Princesses have definitely
changed over the years from having
totally stereotypical personalities to
becoming headstrong individuals
Disney has really stepped up their game
when it comes to character development
which Disney Princess has changed the
most you'll have to watch the video to
find out now let's check out the
evolution of Disney Princesses Snow
White let's start at the very beginning
a very good place to start no wait this
isn't The Sound of Music this is Snow
White and the Seven Dwarfs Snow White is
one of those Disney Princesses people
today have a love/hate relationship with
although she did indeed start the Disney
Princess evolution in general she gets
often criticized for portraying a very
stereotypical female role of course in
those times this was considered to be
the norm Snow White is the typical
damsel in distress critics also
frequently argue that Snow White didn't
really have a personality
apart from being kind there seems to be
nothing assertive about her she's just a
sweet and gentle princess that's waiting
for her prince to sweep her off her feet
[Music]
but despite the fact that Snow White
doesn't really hold modern princess
qualities she's still the reason why
Disney Princesses became so popular to
begin with we have to give her some kind
of credit don't we Cinderella
next on our list is the one and only
cinders as she's only the second Disney
Princess that ever existed we shouldn't
expect anything overly feminists in this
movie
[Music]
Cinderella often gets put in the lower
rankings of progressive princesses but
come on you have to give her credit for
breaking the rules just to go party
relatable although it is true that
Cinderella just wasn't one of those
princesses that would think about
anything else but true love expecting a
man to make your life better was pretty
much a standard for Cinderella and while
that might have been the norm back in
the day female independence is
definitely more valued today Cinderella
did teach just a couple of things about
standing up for our rights and not
putting up with those who are always
bringing us down there are actually a
couple of Disney Princesses from the
early days that were able to break at
least parts of the stereotype and we
salute them although to be completely
honest with you
our next disney princess is not a part
of that group Aurora perhaps one of the
princesses that definitely doesn't get
talked about a lot you can't deny it
Aurora's beautiful but her storyline
pretty much follows what we've seen in
Snow White and Cinderella well except
for this iconic moment that doesn't get
enough credit
of course the hilarious part only lasts
for those 5 seconds and then we're back
to the same old same old Sleeping Beauty
also gave us this moment which terrified
us all back when we were kids and this
one too
[Music]
and of course the movie itself gave
birth to Maleficent iconic character
so while Aurora might not have been a
particularly progressive princess she is
definitely important to the entire
franchise let's not forget that Aurora
was pretty much asleep for most of the
movie and she portrayed a very typical
damsel in distress and she met the guy
in the forest and already declared that
he was the love of her life just a few
moments later ah Aurora we love you we
really do but we bub you more if you'd
have more lines in this movie thank you
next Ariel this is where the popularity
of Disney Princesses began to skyrocket
Ariel was just one of those princesses
everyone fell in love with although her
role is still largely the same as the
princesses we've already mentioned Ariel
was put in a brand new world at the
world underwater and that put a brand
new perspective on everything seriously
if under the sea song isn't stuck in
your head it will after this and we're
sorry the music of the Little Mermaid
was just of a new level and it's by far
the catchiest music created out of the
Disney movies mentioned above but Ariel
does have some good qualities to her too
for example she craves a change and
wants it more than anything for the
people and she actually goes for it and
goes against the rules yep and it still
involves falling in love with a man who
kind of saves her but hey the music
really makes the storyline just a little
bit better though after Ariel came Belle
and mrs. wind Disney started to
experiment with the storyline and the
characters princesses also started to
gain more personality that's outside of
the norm they'll definitely had some
good qualities that tend to outweigh the
bad she's not quite there yet to be
considered a full on progressive
princess but she's definitely
appreciated she's one of the first
characters to yearn for an adventure and
she recognizes misogyny when she sees it
take that Gaston she's also a total
bookworm who's pretty much read every
book there is steering sword fights but
many criticize how the whole romance
between Belle and the beasts actually
started
[Music]
critics have a problem with the way
beasts sometimes threatens violence
which definitely isn't okay although
that doesn't take away from the fact
that bail did actually fall in love for
the right reasons instead of just
falling for the best looking prints
around Princess Jasmine let's be honest
everything changed when Jasmine came
into the picture it's like she opened up
a whole new world of Disney get it
okay okay we'll stop but princess
Jasmine was the very first step of
Disney exploring a slightly different
personality side to Disney Princesses
while Ariel was definitely playful
Jasmine was the first to have a sassy
attitude that doesn't really put up with
anything she also totally owned her
beauty and her lifestyle plus her pet is
a tiger an actual tiger we're pretty
sure Snow White would have ran away if
she ever saw a tiger up close she's also
the first princess that doesn't
immediately tie the knot with the man
she meets it took a while for her to
even warm up to Aladdin and consider him
boyfriend material
of course marriage was still on the
table later on but it was clear that
this was her own choice and decision and
let's not forget that her fashion is
pretty much awesome too Pocahontas
Pocahontas is often ranked as one of the
most progressive Disney princesses ever
yep ever not just among the old-school
prentices but ever jasmine and her are
proof that Disney has taken a huge leap
from the stereotypical role of damsel in
distress and explored other options
instead
but people I guess can like that
Pocahontas is incredibly strong fierce
and independent she knows how to put
John Smith in its place and she wasn't
going to let people control anything in
her life and it's not just the Disney
princess herself Pocahontas is the first
official Disney princess to have a real
life story think I'm an ignorant Savage
and you've been so many places is also
the first one to really talk back to a
man and serve quite a few truths that
even most men today wouldn't be able to
handle let me show you nothing's
happening honestly she's a true
inspiration she's also the first to have
not one but two romances plus she pretty
much realizes that John Smith just isn't
it and not to mention she's totally
gorgeous we bow down to the first Disney
Princess feminists who really made us
see Disney movies in a different way
Mulan okay guys now we're going
somewhere it gets really exciting from
this moment on Pocahontas seemed to have
inspired Disney to finally explore
different cultures and portray Disney
Princesses and more than just a standard
stereotypical way Milan also broke the
stereotype that a Disney princess needs
to have a royal blood just like
Pocahontas her story is also based on an
ancient real-life story on top of that
Mulan saves the entire country she's
actually not into stereotypical things
including being restricted to just one
gender she actually saves her father's
life by pretending to be a man and going
into the army itself and just like
Jasmine Mulan also has a totally
unexpected pet companion it's a dragon
this daring princess trains just like a
man in the army would and no one even
notices a difference which proves a very
important point you took away my victory
I did Milan was definitely one of those
movies that showed the girls they don't
have to stay in their comfort zone and
do the typical girly things honestly
it's one of the most feminist movies
ever and we love it
you don't meet a girl like that every
dynasty Tiana
although Tiana came after Mulan and
Pocahontas she's probably one of the
most underrated Disney Princesses ever
Gianna your daddy may not have gotten
the place you always wanted but he had
something better especially since she's
extremely progressive and not to mention
she's the first princess of
african-american heritage Disney really
decided to make its franchise inclusive
to most and it's greatly appreciated
Tiana is totally independent and she
actually works but not because she was
forced to by someone like an evil
stepmother it's because she has a dream
of running her own restaurant and she
knows it'll take hard work to achieve
that she doesn't wish upon the stars she
makes it happen and that's pretty admire
belite seriously we could go on and on
about Tiana she also ignores any
advances made by men which again proves
that Disney moved on from thinking a
woman should fall for the first man she
meets and although she does eventually
fall in love with a handsome prince
who's actually a rogue she still remains
in complete control of her life as a
result her dreams come true she's not a
damsel in distress
instead she becomes a powerful woman
with her own restaurant Rapunzel
okay Rapunzel's just awesome this is
where the true modern Disney with viral
music and awesome animation really
begins the original Rapunzel story isn't
exactly inspiring but Disney totally
modernized it and it definitely worked
not to mention her Pat is an actual
chameleon who which is pretty impressive
start on the chores and sweep through
the floors all clean and you can forget
about Rapunzel's unexpected fighting
skills she really knows what to do with
that frying pan and we appreciate that
Disney didn't put her in the kitchen
nope she uses that frying pan to fight
[Music]
if that's not a metaphor
we're not sure what is Rapunzel can
pretty much do it all she has a billion
hobbies sure that's because she's been
locked up in a tower for all of her life
and hasn't seen any of the world but you
can't deny that her painting skills are
impressive
[Music]
and although Flynn becomes Rapunzel's
love she is more focused on the lanterns
and the meaning behind them she doesn't
lose her focus and it pays off not to
mention she's able to walk in a
restaurant full of terrifying men and
she makes them all sing their hearts out
[Music]
Merida and here comes the Disney
princess that changed everything
although the progressive princesses
we've mentioned so far were extremely
vital to Disney's princess evolution
Merida really set an important benchmark
lead you to your feet oh not only does
this princess go against her family
traditions and take a similar route as
Mulan there are also no men in the
picture well at least no men that could
be married as potential interests
because there is a thing with an
arranged marriage but we won't talk
about that the whole focus is on Merida
proving herself and her skills to show
her mom she's worth more than she thinks
not to mention Merida completely defies
any Disney princess look with her
flaming red hair plus she's the only
princess with a very visible accent in
her case it's Scottish and the entire
movie features the beautiful sights of
Scotland Disney definitely did a step up
with this one and we're so glad although
there does seem to be a theme with
Disney Princesses and either not having
a mother or having just a not very good
relationship with the mother at the
beginning of the story still Merida is
one of our faves Elsa and Anna
although Anna and Elsa aren't official
Disney Princesses they deserve a spot on
the list
after the viral success of the first
frozen movie
[Music]
can't hold back
although many don't consider Anna and
Elsa to be as progressive as some of the
other modern princesses it's important
to acknowledge a couple of things
sisters aren't often featured in Disney
movies as the main characters and if
they are they don't get along like ever
but it's different with on and Elsa not
only do these two find a sisterly bonds
by the end of the movie they also
discover the importance of self-love
which is exactly what this song is about
[Music]
okay okay we'll stop with let it go we
promise but let's not forget that they
gave us a soundtrack with some of the
best songs ever
[Music]
it's no wonder frozen was such a success
of course Mel interests were involved in
this movie but that wasn't even the main
focus and we're really glad Disney
totally moved away from the stereotype
so yeah we definitely have a soft spot
for Anna and Elsa one of the best sister
duo's there is Moana as of 2018 Moana is
the last Disney Princess that has left a
huge impression on Disney fans at this
point Disney just keeps on getting
better and better by insuring the female
roles in the movies have a lot of
diversity and represent culture from
around the world make way for Moana
[Music]
being the first Polynesian Disney
Princess but one a not only represents a
small culture that's not nearly talked
about she is also completely fearless
and follows her heart she's also able to
put up with and completely shut down a
demigod an actual demigod who's so big
he could probably crush her at any point
but she uses her wit and her sass level
to get what she wants not to mention she
learns how to sail and is determined to
get it right even though she almost lost
her life at sea twice now that's a true
determination this girl clearly knows
her destiny and she doesn't run away
from it she embraces it instead
there's no Prince Charming in sight and
the movie itself is full of unexpected
surprises that make it one of the most
progressive Disney movies ever what's
your fave Disney Princess come let us
know in the comments and that's it for
our video don't forget to hit that like
button subscribe to the things and we'll
see you next time
[Music]